I'm talking to mr.
Doug murray who worked in various capacities
on the harbor bridge when it was being
built. Do you remember when you first got
a job berms to me yes i got through my
father who worked there for seven years. Mr.
Bill my he worked there from
1925 to 1932 and he got
me the job he was the clerk
of works there under a mr.
Jimmy miller who was the engineer in charge
of the pylons who built the pylons and
back to about george street north. What
job did you get first i was an office boy
there first in 1927 i was there. Aged
about fourteen 1/2 and i got a pound
a week do you remember what you had to do
as an office boy. Well i worked for the
timekeeper there and it was just hour and
around and chasing the men for their time
and things like that. Do you remember any
of the bosses around you. Yes there was
mr. As i say mr.
Jimmy or he was in the engineer in charge
of the pi along and. He was responsible
for that and also mr.
Hipwell childhelp well he was in charge
of the arch they were the two main
engineers on the bridge and there were
various other ones. There's a mr.
Ferguson he was in charge
of the crimes crane
a wreck should anybody think. Do you remember
them. Do you remember anything about
them especially. Well. Two
of them. Mr. Muir and mr.
Ferguson the scotchman and. The other
chap was an englishman and that they had
a lot of english and scotch on the job
there. They predominated really the
engineers engineers and workmen as well.
What did you do next after being an office
boy. Well i was there till about
nineteen started nineteen twenty eight.
And then i left there and
served my apprenticeship as
a plumber in the city and things got very
bad in 1931 about this middle of 1931 and
my father who was still the working there.
Got me back on the bridge and they were
putting their hand rails across then
the pipe handrails and he got me in
a gang of plumbers there. There were ten
of us working there and we worked on the
pipe railings or the top arch and the
lower arch and i was there till about
. After the opening and after that i worked.
Cleaning down the power long and we
had to clean them down scrape them down and
with air hoses and water wash them down
. We did that with the stagings the you
know for the riggers put the stagings up.
Do you remember when you were doing the
plumbing handrails up the top with
a curved. Not as far as i know
they went from dawn to staunton
and they were just three quarter black pipe
they were i think they were steam pipe
and they were just greed and weep and they
weren't actually curvy just went from
staunch into two stores is there
a number of people who told me that
everything on the bridge was straight and i
just want to wear that we've got something
that was curved. They weren't there only
about every i think every
ten feet there was
a staunch and so they with the great curvature
of the arch they didn't really need
that for the pipes you know the handrails.
Was it hard work was fairly hard work.
It was very windy out there and you had
to watch yourself and they unease dab
a little rope lifelines
a used to love me. Call them and they had
to be very careful on wet days we won't
allow we didn't work. We came the. Because
of the slippery conditions you get paid
for that. Yes i was very well paid. There
we got height money starting from the
deck. Upwards i got about £8 ten a
week and then on the arch of the £10
a week which was very good money in those
days about double wages. The only thing
jack lalanne used to take a shilling
a week out of it. The taxi just came in and
we thought that was terrible. With the
unemployment tax unemployment tax yet to
pay the people it was unemployed. Yes. To
help. That's what i when i asked you whether
you've got paid. I mean this although
you answered
a number of things there. Good i wanted
to know that but did you get paid for wet
weather. No i don't think so no we didn't
get paid. You only got paid for when you
worked. No holiday. No holiday pay or
anything like that. No super no sick pay
. You remember the anything else about
working up on the ice the conditions up
there. Anything stick in
your mind. Well one day i
slipped really through the staunching and
that and i only just held on by one hand
and i got missiles up and i often just
after that i wondered whether the job was
worth it. You know take me alive
but that was risky you know
a bit and that. But that was all you know.
Do you member any other accidents while
you were there. Yes i was there was
a chap named jimmy campbell the last man
to get killed in the bridge and just after
we finished the handrails on the arch we
worked in the pilings on the rails and
there's
a plumber and i working there. One morning
and jimmy campbell of the foreman rigger
came up he was putting the stagings deal
with these men and he came up and he
walked up very slow and. I knew him
very well my father that he was
a friend of my father's as well and i said
you very seem to be very tired and i'm
a very glad when this job's over to you now
he said and he walked up and. Now half
an hour later these men come down and said
he's gone over. He got caught. There was
a needle there what they put up
a wooden needle where they put the
stagings down and he got caught in and
catapulted over onto the top and he went
down through the railway lines and i was
talking to electrician after it working
and the lights just above. They were
putting the lights there then and the jimmy
missed him by about two or three feet
he said he would have gone to. But when
you look at the railway lines you want to
how body got through but he got through it.
Anyone right at the bottom of the into
the pile on there that was on doors side
and we had the afternoon off in respect
to some of us do you have any amusing
things other than the the more tragic ones.
Well i used to have
a lot to jobs the jokes there about the
things and that the you know so many things
used to fall into the harbour from
underneath specially rules if you're set on
a girder the your ruler go down and i must
as thought about ten rules while i was
there and he was peter to get it and things
used to go down underneath and some of
the chaps reckoned that if it weren't for
another seven years they wouldn't need
a bridge they can walk over with a bit
of concrete on the top you know scrap as
a roadway. Lots of things. Well
a few. Many other amusing things you can
remember. Well as another thing that died
i know whether it was only me that used
to see it really i think sometimes it is
just sad but when of us first
going over there to go down there
a lot on the sats because i was always
interested me father was interested in
showing me that and when they were
getting the steelworkers to meet. Doors.
I think it was the curve on the and north
shore side but it used to look at depot
like. They weren't going to meet at all
and some used to say that we'd finish up
with two bridges you know enough to build
a piling in and eat another piling
each side because i certainly
a joke of course that was there when the
public works were approaches were coming
around to meet the north shire.
So yes i think the public works
built up to about george street north on
the sydney side and the doormen long as i
went up to there with their work and
that. Who only you were as an office boy
timekeeping do you remember how many people
were working there then. Well you mean
counting down the camera you two there was
a you know. Twenty seven twenty
and twenty eight and all that i
don't really know but
there'd be a there was
a fair crowd there would be about seven
or eight hundred people i should think
about right. But the one of the number of
meru you may show they were star masons.
Do you have any do you get out of
a are you at all in later years i did
because my father told me where it was and
that and that he was in charge of checking
the granite. On the wharf when it came
to sydney that was part of his job to check
the ground the sizes and everything.
And doors point but in later years i went
used to go down there and i'm going to to
melbourne and adelaide and camp there
sometimes in the. The old quarry there. What
happened to you after you got laid off
from the bridge. What did you get work or
were you on the dole. Now actually
wasn't on the dole. But we had
a little bit of money. My brother
and i and that and we had
a little farm up on the
hawkesbury river at
a place called our portland and i was
there for four years from 1932 to 1936 we
just saw the depression out there and then
what do you do then. Well then my father
who is a. Also a builder
and that and i was
a plumber and the other
my other brother was
a painter we used to build it or cottages
fibro cottages and we did that up to the
time of the war starting. So i'd like some
of the others. You didn't ever get on
the dole. Now i was actually on relief work
up in the hospital for two years worked
on the road around the hawkesbury there
for two years we used to get twenty four
shillings for about two days work and
a. I used to have to walk ten miles every
second friday at wiseman's ferry to
collect that money which was about twenty
four shillings i think but i would have
was was absent all buttons were yes and
orman's was the other side of. Wisemans
ferry but we worked on the sydney side. We
worked from lower portland till wisemans
fairly on the road the right. Do you
remember the working conditions
on the bridge. What they were like to rember
any union activity are used to be some
not in our section much but they often
used to go on strike there. And the steel
workers and that and what they used to
do sometimes they just walk off and they
wouldn't tell the boss and the boss would
have to find out why they're gone. That
used to be
a common thing. It was nothing like these
days but in their way they used to go on
strike
a bit you know for the conditions. Do you
remember anything any union activity at
all the unions. Where you had to be
a union member to be on there. That's the
only thing and that but i didn't have
much to do with the union. I was just
a union member and that was all. Well.
While you were working as an office boy
in the early days. Is there anything
particularly stands out in your mind here sort
of one's very vivid thing. One night
just before knocking off time about
a quarter fire we used to knock off at
five o'clock. At the time he had gone down
the it was
a ship going to america i
think it's gone down down in
the harbor and a little while later
someone said it was a fairy and it was
a great cliff and. I remember them
a great activity there and the next week
was very bad because if they were looking
at all. The. All the bodies of these poor
little schoolgirls that got to ground
there. It was
a very gloomy week that week. The next
week and i mean member that very vividly
remember anything else and
that time. Oh yes. Another
thing i remember was my father. This was
a saturday. He took one they were demolishing
at the back of the bridge. You know
at sydney's side. He took me down
a street. That's defunct now that's not
their name printed street princes street
and goes back to wynyard there. It was
and he said this of history said this is
that it was
a terrible street. Prostitute and everything
the sailors and in the old days. He
said and you couldn't walk down this street
in the night time he said it was such
a dreadful street. And he said now it's
getting demolished he sent for. The bridge
and that is where the bridge goes back to
wynyard the hand that stuck very vividly
in the memory. Where did you live at
that time i lived there west ride and
had to get to work by trusting him dry and.
Yes. And oh yes of course you were the
bridge was over the arch then and. Yes. Do
you member what used to do in your spare
time. If you had
a bit of money in your pocket. Did you used
to go into the city dancing or the pubs
or what. Now the only thing i didn't know
was one of six children and. We didn't
have much money to spend but i used to go
in every saturday afternoon and go to the
vaudeville and shows and that the fullers
and the old tivoli and i used to watch.
Jim gerald and ones like that on easter
love that that was my main. Otherwise it
was all work and going to take and did you
play any sport. While you were on the
bridge only swimming i used to be
a great swimmer and surfer raced
a lot that there are different ever involved
in cricket in the test match for the
workshop. Now remember.
I remember eight years
mrs. Halliday's tells
the quite a bit about.